now one important little gotcha here
which I'm sure didn't actually fall
through your example was the calling of
this dot world clear forces every frame
now this is an important point in our
physics engine implementation typically
in a physics engine you'd set the
velocity toss around some objects and be
on with your day the reason for this is
that box2d assumes that you are in a two
dimensional environment with the gravity
vector always pointing down as such if
you were to create an object and throw
it through the world the gravity forces
on it would actually move it downward
however in grits this is not the correct
policy what we'd like to do is for
projectile to move forward along a
straight path without vertical gravity
influencing however because we're a
top-down game and don't have a gravity
vector any small velocity vector gets
accumulated on our physics object each
frame without friction and I'm going to
continue bouncing around in the
environment or rather you should think
of gravity as something that produces
friction on an object slowing its
velocity we fix this sort of gliding
hockey puck motion by reducing the
influence of the physics engine on our
world namely we allow the velocity of an
object to be set for a given frame the
physics engine to move that object and
compute the position and rotation and
collisions and then at the end of the
frame we erase and remove that velocity
vector now unless we reapply a velocity
vector the next frame the object will
sit in its position not moving